the Bachelorette is just heating up or
should I say the train is already off
the tracks last night it was revealed
that Kaitlyn the Bachelorette actually
had sex with one of the contestant oh it
is a crazy drama I boarded to make some
great TV right I mean she's crying the
guys are crying her guys are crying yes
they're crying my big mess well earlier
today I sat down with her right here for
some girl talk
what was she thinking everybody waits
until the fantasy suite so why did you
have sex so soon because that's how I
felt in that moment that's the only way
to explain it me to admit but we had sex
I don't think that's a crazy thing to
sleep with somebody you know like when
you're trying to be in a relationship
with them cameras called Kaitlyn and the
mystery bachelor in her hotel room and
what happened next the criticism some
are calling slut-shaming you know what
you do
you even realize how you're making us
feel try a lot of people are coming to
your fence saying come on she's a grown
woman she can make up her own mind I'm a
30 year old woman and I make my own
decisions and intimacy to me as part of
a relationship I don't know why everyone
is so shocked by it I think part of it
was people thought that you felt ashamed
about it I felt upset that it could have
jeopardized other relationships that I
cared about but at the same time it is
the show and that could have happened in
the fantasy suite
the man rumored to have slept with
Caitlyn is Nick vile from the last
season of The Bachelorette
remember when he publicly outed Andi
Dorfman if you weren't in love with me I
like why you made love of him well it
was revealed last night that Nick
returns in an upcoming episode okay the
rumor is it is Nick that you slept with
as well find out do you regret sleeping
with that particular Bachelor I'm not
ashamed I just regret the timing of it